hey this is pressure Walker a child
spent $100 to get 100 toy animals the
child bought at least one cat one fish
and one bird and did not buy any other
toys if a cat cost $10 a fish cost $3
and a bird cost 50 cents how many of
each toy did the child buy can you
figure it out give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution
since the child bought 100 toys in total
we know the number of cats plus the
number of fish plus the number of birds
is equal to 100
furthermore the child spent $100 in
total and we know the cost of each toy
this leads to the equation that 10 times
the number of cats plus 3 times the
number of fish plus 0.5 times the number
of birds is equal to 100 let's simplify
these equations from the first equation
we'll solve for the number of birds this
will be the number of birds is equal to
100 minus the number of cats minus the
number of fish we can substitute that
into the second equation
well now simplify this and then we'll
simplify it further we end up that 19
times the number of cats plus 5 times
the number of fish is equal to 100 let's
continue from this equation well solve
for the number of fish we have the
number of fish is equal to 20 minus the
number of cats times 19 over 5 this will
be the key equation to deduce the answer
the variable cats is being multiplied by
19 over 5 now we need the number of fish
to be a whole number and we know that
the number of cats is also a whole
number this means the number of cats has
to be a multiple of 5 so that the number
of fish is a whole number furthermore we
need the number of fish to be a number
that's greater than zero we're taking 20
minus the number of cats times 19 over 5
so we can figure out that the number of
cats has to be less than 100 over 19 or
approximately 5.26 so that the number of
fish
is greater than zero so we need a
multiple of five that's less than about
five point two six and we know that the
number of cats is also greater than zero
so what number is a multiple of five
that's greater than zero but less than
five point two six there's only one
possibility which is that the number of
cats is equal to five so if uniquely
solve for the number of cats and we can
substitute that value to get that the
number of fish has to equal one we now
need to figure out the number of birds
but we know the total number of animals
is equal to 100 so we can then say that
the number of birds is equal to ninety
four and this is the unique solution to
this problem did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch run
on my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at pressure Locker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description